but the MVP named in his honor
hall-of-famer
and one of the all-time greats mr. Bill
Russell and with us to present the 2019
MVP of the NBA Finals Adam Silver again
Thank You Doris and of course here with
Bill Russell on the 50th anniversary of
your 11th and final championship thank
you for being here and our MVP following
an iconic buzzer beater and a dominant
performance in the finals
year 2019 Bill Russell Finals MVP is
Kawhi Leonard
Hawaiian congratulations why throughout
the course of this series you touched on
the fact that a year ago you were not
playing basketball and you had to make
your way to a new city with new
teammates but one thing that never
seemed to waver was your poise and your
confidence what gives you that steely
resolve oh man just life experiences my
teammates they did a great job of you
know welcomed me with open arms the
management so that I just want me to
come out and play basketball you know oh
my god I just you know trying to not get
too high or too low and it worked out it
worked out you join I know you you make
it very clear that you are about winning
and not records nor anything else but
tonight fight by winning your second MVP
of the finals with a different team you
join select company Kareem and LeBron
James as you let that sink in what
crosses your mind man last summer man
was going through a lot was going
through a lot
yeah
you know I had a great support system I
just kept working hard working hard and
have my mind set on this goal right here
I came to a team I'm no post that myself
was the same as mine trying to get
trying to get that Larry Obi over there
and you know this is what I play
basketball for this is what I workout
for all summer during this season and
I'm happy that my hard work paid off I
know you're gonna celebrate this but I
know Jurassic Park 37 million people the
men behind you you have such an
important decision movie how does a
championship shape what you have in
front of you I'm about to enjoy this
with my teammates and coaches and I
think about that later
shoo-shoo congratulations